the character of Saul shows up nine
years ago on Breaking Bad a show that
killed beloved characters left and right
right and here you are all these years
later on really successful and beloved
spin-off but weren't you you must have
thought when you first showed up oh yeah
and your saw oh you're not gonna lie
thought I was created to die I was made
to die well we've all been made to die
[Applause]
why did you all just cheer the concept
of our works happen it's so weird well
they like truth Conan yeah the most
existentially aware audience yeah
they're really it is famous you're
famous they're all smoking right now
just that truly is true we all die but
it's it's I did I opened every script of
Breaking Bad thinking this is my time
because he was a perfect character to
kill off he was kind of important but he
didn't really matter to the main story
right Oh wouldn't he have been something
also it just it really did feel like I
think that one of the first times I saw
your character you had like a bag over
your head and they're just about to you
arted with you almost I think you had a
gun held your head on that show more
than anybody else it always felt like
well this is the one where Sol finally
go yeah right you've out you'll outlast
everybody it's a well there you go you
can't predict anything
you